good morning John in the last video you
were like you always have punishment and
I was like I do we've been do this for a
long time there's been a lot of
punishable infractions so it's gonna
confuse luckily a bunch of nerdfighters
led by the indestructible Valery 27 76
have created a spreadsheet in which all
of our punishments and the reasons why
we had them have been listed and now as
a reminder and also a history lesson and
also to figure out what the heck is
going on I'm converting a spreadsheet
into a video and because I do know when
I get punished I'm going very fast on
January 1st 2007 we created this channel
with three rules one you have to make a
video on your day two the video can't be
longer than four minutes long and three
Hank and John Green cannot communicate
textually first rules broke in that very
same month when John UC saved me on an
email to someone else which Canada's
text to communication you had to wax the
Chile later I did the exact same things
he's seeing John and had to reenact
three of my most embarrassing moments
with sock puppets I also once wrote see
you tomorrow in text in the end of a
video as a result I had to go out on the
streets of Missoula and tried to give
away peeps which is how I met Kurt the
punk-rock nerdfighter in July I just I
am to you and then you replied so we
both got punished we did a shared
punishment both dressing up like the
most embarrassing picture we could find
from high school March you missed a
video because you were hospitalized and
who accidentally replied to me on a
forum and so you had to eat a blender
eyes happy meal wax your legs and like a
cat I'm not sure why there were three
possibly something about donations to
Daniel Biss is campaign finally in
December of 2007 during the first
project for awesome I replied to a
comment that you left on a project for
awesome video and thus had to blend
together peeps and Strawberry Hill
flavored citrus wine and drink it while
playing a show to six people not a boob
no me except for my wife my first show
ever for the rest of vlog brothers we
abolished the textual communication rule
so now John and I can email each other
which is helpful also alter the schedule
in various different ways and made time
limit exemptions for educational videos
videos with montages in them and videos
that are four minutes in one second long
because YouTube adds a second why
YouTube why'd you out a second in April
of 2008 I'm at a video that was 14
seconds too long I don't know why I just
messed up that we as a result I had to
sing the song world-wide-web girl with
pigtails in my hair and in October I
accidentally put 30 seconds of
nothingness on the end of my video which
resulted to me dancing around my house
dressed like Carrie Bradshaw from Sex in
the City while singing Rick Astley's
never gonna be welcome
the infamous Hank roll in June of 2008
you missed a video and had to eat a
sandwich made out of lard and protein
meal and in November I made a video that
was two seconds too long and I had to
spend 15 hours in a target Oh
during VidCon 2010 both of us failed to
upload our video videos in response to
that where your amazing fitness for
nerds video and my Katniss Everdeen
makeup tutorial 2011 a long-standing
agreement to be punished of Helen Hunt
ever saw my Helen Hunt video came to
fruition he sent me a tweet and then I
had to hump my entire town in 2012 there
were no punishments but there may have
been some punishable infractions I'll
get to that soon in 2013 the very first
punishment dealt to someone who wasn't
you or me was dealt to grace Helbig for
making a video longer than four minutes
during your paternity leave it's not
entirely clear whether the rules applied
to her she slapped herself anyway John
in October of 2013 you made of longer
than four minute video that was deemed
to not be educational enough and so you
were punished you ate slobber carrots
made by your son here's where it gets
confusing and someone will eventually
clear this up but it is very clear in
we both odd punishments I can't figure
out what they were for I know that there
were punishments because on October 28th
you made a bet with nerdfighter you know
some of you and I had outstanding
punishments but if we could get to a
thousand videos before nerdfighteria
loaned a million dollars through
kiva.org those punishments would be
wiped clean however if they got to a
million dollars first we would double
our punishments we would both have to of
course never underestimate nerdfighteria
a million dollars was indeed loaned so
we each had two punishments we absolved
one of them by doing six videos in a
week three which leaves finally one
punishment each it was your own doing
John you can't complain John I got a
really good idea from the comments for
your video about what my punishments
gonna be so everybody leave comments for
what John is gonna do in his punishment
John I will see you on Tuesday